- [Instructor] Sikhism comes
into being in northern India
in a time when the Mughals
are coming into power.
What we see in this blue area
is what the first Mughal emperor, Babur,
is able to put under his control,
which includes the region of Punjab,
which is where Sikhism begins
and thrives to this day.
We see later emperors like
Akbar continuing to expand
the domain of the Mughal
emperor with Aurangzeb,
the least tolerant of the Mughals,
expanding well into South India.
It all starts in the 15th
century with the birth
of who will eventually
be known as Guru Nanak.
He's born into a merchant
class Hindu family,
and he is known to be precocious
from a very young age,
especially when it comes
to matters of spirituality.
He is constantly questioning.
He goes and learns
about various religions.
Remember, North India is under
the control of the Muslims,
but it's a Hindu-majority population,
and you also have populations
of Christians and Jains.
And this is also a time, as
we've studied in other videos,
where the Bhakti movement is on the rise,
this notion of devotional
love to God within Hinduism,
and it's in this context that Guru Nanak
becomes a significant, some
would say, Bhakti guru.
To get a sense of some of his teachings:
"There is but one God.
"His name is Truth.
"He is without hate.
"He is beyond the cycle
of births and deaths.
"He is Self illuminated."
So just in this excerpt
of some of his sayings,
you see elements of the core of Hinduism
and elements of Islam.
There is but one God, a
central tenet of Islam.
But then, these ideas that really come
from a Vedic tradition.
God is beyond the cycle of
births and deaths, samsara.
He is self illuminated.
There's a lot of mention
of your inner self,
your true self, is one with this God.
"Even kings and emperors
"with heaps of wealth and vast dominion
"cannot compare with an ant
filled with the love of God."
So here, you see this Bhakti influence,
and you can see why he's considered
a major Bhakti guru or Bhakti saint.
He's emphasizing this
devotional love of God.
"The world is a drama staged in a dream."
So here, you have the Hindu,
the Vedic notions of Maya.
The world is an illusion.
His followers will
eventually be known as Sikhs,
and the word Sikh comes
from the Sanskrit word
for to learn or learning,
and it's related to the word for student.
And even in modern Sanskrit-derived
languages like Hindi,
you have words like sikhna,
which means to learn.
Guru Nanak dies in the early 16th century.
You can see by this point,
the Mughals have taken
control of northern India.
And before his death, he names Guru Angad,
who is not his son, as his successor.
After Guru Angad, you have Guru Amar Das,
and then you have Guru Ram
Das, who establishes the city
now sacred to Sikhs known as Amritsar,
originally known as Ramdaspur.
Guru Dam Das is succeeded
on his death by Guru Arjan.
And Guru Arjan is
significant for many reasons.
He creates the compilation
known as the Adi Granth,
which are the sayings and the
hymns of the previous gurus,
including his own.
The Adi Granth, as we will
see, will eventually evolve
into the Guru Granth
Sahib, which is considered
not only the Sikh holy book
but also the last and final of the gurus.
In Ramdaspur, later to
be known as Amritsar,
Guru Arjan builds the Harmandir Sahib,
which is intended to be a place of worship
for people of all religions.
They have a tradition of langar,
where they feed anyone
who comes from any faith,
and today the Harmandir Sahib
would later be known as the Golden Temple
where later Raja would plate it with gold,
is the largest free kitchen in the world.
Guru Arjan is also known
as the first martyr in the Sikh faith.
As we've told about,
the early Mughals were
relatively tolerant.
Akbar in particular
was extremely tolerant.
But upon his death, his
son Jahangir takes power,
and early in Jahangir's reign,
he is insecure about his hold on power.
And remember, the Mughals are ruling
from the same region where the Sikhs
are having an increasingly
growing following,
not just from Hindus
but also from Muslims.
Threatened by this growing following,
Jahangir imprisons Guru
Arjan and tortures Guru Arjan
trying to get him to renounce the faith
to convert to Islam.
Guru Arjan refuses despite many days
of excruciating torture
being boiled alive.
Eventually, he dies and there's
slightly varying accounts
of how it happens.
After his death, his
son, who will be known
as Guru Hargobind comes to power,
and Guru Hargobind, as
legend has it on direction
from his father before he would die,
tells him that the Sikhs
need to protect themselves.
They need to adopt a military tradition
to protect themselves from the oppression
especially the oppression
from the Mughals.
So, Guru Hargobind, he is
famous for establishing
the military tradition of Sikhism.
He is the first guru to
be what you could call
a warrior saint.
He's famous for wearing two swords.
One to represent his authority
in the spiritual realm
and another to represent
his authority in the temporal realm.
He also has the longest tenure as guru.
At Guru Hargobind's death,
his grandson, Guru Har Rai becomes guru.
At his death, his very
young son, Guru Har Krishan
becomes guru but dies of smallpox.
Afterwhich, Guru Hargobind's
youngest son becomes guru.
He is named eventually Guru Tegh Bahadur
which means brave sword or
brave wielder of the sword
because as his father, Guru
Hargobind, fought the Mughals,
he was known as being unusually brave
and an unusually competent warrior.
He continued this tradition
of being a warrior saint
and especially under the rule
of Shah Jahan and Aurangzeb
as the Mughals became
more and more intolerant
and started force conversions,
he viewed himself as a
protector of the oppressed,
not just of the Sikhs
but the oppressed of any
faiths including Hindus
who are being forced to
convert by Aurangzeb.
Eventually, Aurangzeb
tortures and kills him
for refusing to convert to Islam
and he is considered the
second guru who is martyred.
At his death, we have the
tenth and last human guru
of the Sikh tradition, Guru Gobind Singh,
who continues, again, this
tradition of a warrior saint
and actually formalizes it
in this notion of Khalsa.
There's a famous story of him
gathering the Sikh community
and asking for volunteers.
And the first volunteer
he takes into a tent
and then he emerges from that tent
without the volunteer with a bloody sword
giving people the impression
that he might have killed that individual.
Then, he asked for more volunteers
and more people coming.
Every time, he comes out of
the tent without the volunteers
but with a bloody sword.
But after five volunteers have come,
they all emerged from the tent.
He makes it clear that
this was an exercise
as a test of faith to see who was willing
to risk their life to follow the cause.
And he says, "These are the Khalsa,
"these are these are the pure.
"Together, we are going to be
a group to fight oppression
"wherever it might be."
And he formalizes what it means to be
one of these warrior saints.
Famously, with the Five K's of Khalsa
that anyone who goes into
the Khalsa indoctrination
who becomes a Khalsa sikh,
they should not cut their
hair, this is known as Kesh,
they should wear a metal
bracelet known as Kara,
they should have a wooden
comb known as Kanga,
and they should carry
a short dagger or sword
known a Kirpan and there is Kaccherra
which is often an undergarment worn
and has a symbolic meaning.
A man who goes through
the Khalsa ceremony,
the Khalsa baptism,
adopts the title of Singh
which means lion,
and a woman who does adopts
the title, Kaur or princess,
and it's essentially, they are
promising to fight oppression
wherever it might be.
Guru Gobind Singh is also famous
for the final compilation
of what would be known
as the Guru Granth Sahib.
Taking the Adi Granth which
was compiled by Guru Arjan
and adding the 115 hymns
of Guru Tegh Bahadur who was martyred,
and making this collection of
hymns not just from the gurus
but from saints and gurus in the Hindu
and Muslim tradition as well
and declaring that this
is the 11th and final guru
and sikhs today view the Guru Granth Sahib
as their guru.
If you were to visit a
gurdwara which is their temple,
it means door to the gurus, dwara,
same root in Sanskrit as door,
you will see it houses a Guru Granth Sahib
which the Sikhs will venerate
and view as their guru.